All right. Now that we've covered some of the basics
of interviewing for autonomous systems rules,
let's get started on watching interviews.
Remember, over the next few videos,
you'll watch various candidates for different roles
approach a problem given to them by their interviewers.
For each candidate considered taking notes on how they approach the problem,
what they could do well or can improve on and anything else you find important.
After each video, you'll have a chance to reflect on their performance.
Really try to put yourself in the interviewer's shoes as to how the candidate performed.
If you were the hiring manager or a teammate for someone hiring in this role,
is this someone you trust to be capable and
competent in performing the job responsibilities?
Not every one of these candidates will have a perfect response.
After you've gotten a chance to reflect,
you'll hear from the interviewer themselves as well.
Make sure to compare their thoughts against your own.
I'll see you again after the interviews.